is your plan to have inflation working
prime minister
is the prime minister about to block pay
Rises for public sector workers what do
we want there hey when do we want it
it's a standoff that has caused strikes
and Rising tensions between unions and
ministers over months now number 10 is
considering recommendations from
independent pay review bodies and won't
say whether they'll step in if they
think they're too high
what Rishi sunak and his Chancellor have
said repeatedly though is that keeping
down inflation is the priority and
Rising wages could put that at risk it's
not about economics there's just no
evidence that public sector pay is
driving inflation in fact our public
sector workers have seen their pay fall
in real terms for over a decade but many
conservative MPS believe the
government's approach will pay off in
the end the Prime Minister has very very
difficult positions but this is probably
his most difficult decision and he's
fully seized of it as Chancellor he's
got his mind all over the numbers as I
say we learned from the 70s and the 90s
that once this domestic inflation gets
embedded it's very difficult to get rid
of and it affects everybody
and he made his position clear once
again this week saying that whilst pay
offers need to be fair wage price
spirals are not going to help anybody
but does this mean the Prime Minister
could go as far as overrule calling the
independent pay bodies I would be pretty
concerned if if they actually chose to
overturn in any significant way I think
there's a middle course which is
um except but don't fully fund
um which means they will look for
efficiencies from departments it's just
another problem looming over number 10
and a prime minister determined to put
the economy first whatever the cost Liz
Bates Sky News Westminster